what's up everyone big day in the geek
culture Studio we had so many guys here
because as you can see in front of me
this was a device announced in CS just a
few weeks ago
it's now on our Shores here in Singapore
this is the Asus Zenbook 17 fold OLED in
the house one of three in the world
making its kind of World Tour mind due
to a very selective few journalists we
are lucky to have it in the studios here
now this is a prototype we cannot give
it a full review we're gonna give you
our first impressions but this
it's freaking awesome man check this out
a 17.3 inch display you fold that in
half it goes 12.5 inch it can be a
laptop it can be a display as a
Bluetooth keyboard there is so much
going on inside of this thing
we're gonna dive into it Zach are you
pumped for this yeah
yeah that's what I'm talking about Xeno
are you pumped for this yeah
Gerald are you pumped
yeah that didn't sound too pumped man
we're gonna get you in the gym Gerald
2022 baby okay let's get into this let's
talk a little bit about Spec's here for
a month now this is a partnership
between Intel and Asus you got the 12th
gen i7 processor it's the 1250u so it's
the ultra low energy processor inside of
this thing then you got the Boe display
which Asus is also partnering with
because you have a 2.5 KO OLED display
on this P3 color gamuts you name it this
thing is stacked absolutely beautiful
true Rich deep blacks foldable do you
see the crease it's a lot of you can ask
that question I'm going to show you that
in just a second but let's talk a little
bit about the design first and foremost
we'll put the Bluetooth keyboard out of
the way here let's pick this thing up
the weight is about 1.4 kg without the
Bluetooth keyboard this is about 290
grams thereabouts have that on about you
know my math isn't the greatest 1.65
1.69 kilos you know it's easy to pop
into a backpack you're good to go but
look at this thing for a second
absolutely stunning
this is a thing of beauty
and you want to know something look at
the top look at the top part of this
look at this gloss blue Jackie do you
see this gloss blue right here man it's
like looking like if you're down in the
ocean yes and they look up yes
yeah it's like
hitting the ocean is that right dude I
love that sake that's beautiful oh my
God I didn't think about that you're
right so you know do you agree with that
um
that's all you have to say
it's beautiful
xenos that lost for words
Encino
anyway let's get back into it for a
second here now when we look at this of
course you do have a five megapixel
front uh camera here and this display is
very durable you can touch on it tap on
it this is not one of those soft
displays that you have to baby this is
actually a very pretty robust display
now again it's not water resistant it's
a foldable display but this is more
durable than you might think it is
because you can actually type on this
you can draw on this I hear there may be
a stylus in the future that you can
utilize with this as well but just
looking at this display right now is
absolutely stunning and you go from 17.3
inches to 12.5 just like that
and here's the cool thing
look at the mechanism that's inside of
this if you go close to this we'll give
you a close-up on this there's actually
a curvature in here so you don't get
much of a crease on the display this is
one of the most important things because
when we talk about foldable displays
that's the question everybody asks is
there going to be a crease is it going
to bother me when I look at my content
and the answer is no you see it it's
there but it's not going to bother you
so much
because it's really well designed you've
got two Thunderbolt 4 ports on this of
course you've got your headphone jack
because you got to have a headphone jack
on this you got speaker ports you got
speakers right there and uh yeah you can
charge this with a 5 watt or 20 watt a
USBC charger and it's a 75 watt battery
to this so it's going to last you for a
pretty decent length of time on this no
problems at all with that talking about
the graphics card you're probably
wondering you probably read this website
but if you haven't it is a iris XC
graphics card inside of this it sort of
Intel's built-in graphics card so this
is not going to be like a pro art laptop
you're not going to be running Premiere
Pro and you know uh hardcore Photoshop
or anything like that right this is
going to be more for your day-to-day
usage you know YouTube videos watching
Netflix sending out emails things like
that you can do a little bit of editing
on this but it's not designed to be your
pro art laptop that Asus makes okay so
keep that in mind but for the most part
this is a very versatile thing because I
didn't show you something really cool
with this yet so if we open it up you
see this 12.5 inch display right right
you've seen that
17 inch display right right while you're
thinking but what am I going to do with
the 17 inch display I can hold it like
this and I can you know maybe I can read
yes you can you can let's like reading a
book if you want if you're a you know
let's say you're a musician you're
learning singing you could have your
your score there you can do this I'm
like that if you wanted to I'm not a
singer mind you what if I showed you
that you could actually take this move
it to the back here there is a stand
and now people now you have a display in
front of you a 17 inch display you can
move the stand back if you want
and then you just take the Bluetooth
keyboard
and now I have
essentially a desktop computer
like this now of course you can you know
connect a mouse to it if you want to use
it you can use the trackpad right here
all right in this situation now thinking
yourself well what do I do with the
Bluetooth keyboard right do I just have
to pack that in my bag too no as you can
see you want to apply one what do I do
with the keyboard well you see these
bezels right right around here these are
actually soft rubber feels really good
at the touch it's actually quite very
nice
anyway they are meant for another reason
as well I put the keyboard here
it magnetizes
and then
a close the Zenbook 17 fold
and now I have a 12.5 inch laptop
that I can take with me
and I have a keyboard right there
ready to go
I take the keyboard out don't need any
more put it to the side
and we are ready to rock and roll
and I also have a keyboard on the
display too
look at this
this is the future of where laptops are
going guys I'm this is it
it's going to be an all-in-one device
sooner or later this is going to happen
I know everybody like well I like my
teacher of them and I like mechanical
keys I get it okay we have people using
mechanical keyboards here it sounds
annoying after a while whoa whoa it's
true
it sounds annoying because we can't do
any videos when you're typing Gerald
it's just the truth right right Jackie
yeah right Xeno yeah
I don't
I don't and now I have a full-size
keyboard in front of me as you can see
right here we've got notepad right there
so I'm gonna actually be uh you know
showing how it's typing Xeno is right
behind me what's up Xenia there he is
all right here we go so I'm not the best
typer in the world so I'm kind of like a
pigeon typer excuse me on that point
oh
Fox
go to the store who made this sentence
up I did a quick brown fox jumps away my
sentence is how did the brown fox go to
the store that's what I wrote it has
makes no sense whatsoever but I just
wrote it down because that's all came to
my mind right Xeno right right exactly
just right what comes to our mind
recruit we're creative people
anyway as you can see you got feedback
on this you got sound of course you can
turn that off if you want but you have a
full-size keyboard on this and then you
can get into emojis look at this you
love this stuff series Xeno this is all
you baby right here as you know is our
Tick Tock guy right all this stuff you
see on Tick Tock is from them he loves
this [ __ ] this is where his wheelhouse
is at anyway I can't say [ __ ] on the
video but he loves this crap this is
worth
He loves this stuff this is where his
wheelhouse is at right so that's where
we're at so we can add you know a little
bit of a you know gifts we can add all
that great stuff there we got emojis
Hearts all that it's all built into the
keyboard here tap the keyboard and bring
it back if I don't want it anymore get
rid of the keyboard and by the way
this is a Bluetooth keyboard you don't
even have to use this keyboard with this
if you don't want to you have a keyboard
let's say another Asus keyboard or
another brand like here's a message from
our sponsor Logitech here again culture
we love our keyboards especially with
the all-new Logitech MX Keys mini an
elegant and functional keyboard it's
Ultra responsive rounded keycaps are
super stable and quiet for more
productivity there are buttons to enable
dictation microphone audio control and
emojis the backlit Keys illuminate when
you get close and matches the lighting
of the environment you're in it lasts up
to 10 days on a full charge or 5 months
with the back lights turned off to find
out more about the Logitech MX Keys mini
and their latest range of products head
over to logitech.com so one more thing
about this keyboard it's a Bluetooth
keyboard so you can use this on other
devices as well it's not just paired to
the Zenbook 17 fold okay and even if you
have your own personal keyboard that you
love it's Bluetooth and you you feel
more comfortable with that you can also
pair it to the the Zenbook 17 as well so
you've got some options with it but I
would definitely say this is the
keyboard you're going to want to get
with this because it pairs beautifully
with it if it's right inside of it it's
designed to work with this keyboard and
as a matter of fact the the travel on
this is actually really nice it's got
nice travel feels relatively good in the
hands uh yeah I think you're gonna like
this a lot good option here and the
trackpad is also very responsive which
is important because sometimes a lot of
these little track pads can be hit or
missed Asus did a great job with this
trackpad and it really does work well
okay so
I've shown you typing I've shown you how
it Folds
a lot of you out there goes you know I
use my laptop and maybe I'm watching The
Book of Boba Fett right now by the way
episode five was awesome wasn't it
spoilers anyway you might want to watch
a movie you might want to watch a TV
series so how is the display for that
and how is the sound okay
again get ready to be impressed so what
I'm gonna do is I'm going to show you uh
we're now in our D culture YouTube page
right now and we shoot everything in 4k
we like our 4K so we're actually going
to show you our one of our camera
reviews I've done here hey everyone
what's going on that's me we're back
talking about cameras once again and the
Canon R3 this could be my long-term
review I did a first impressions we're
gonna put a link right here look at this
back then I had very minimal time with
that camera I've had this in my hand for
the past few weeks over the Christmas
for this camera and it may be a month
before it comes to your local camera
shop or online so hopefully this video
will uh give you a little relief in the
meantime how awesome do that sound Xeno
oh it's loud you're an audio guy right
that's loud right it's loud but it's
good Zaki what do you think loud and
proud loud and proud that's what we like
it but here's the thing with the audio
now in terms of the bass it's not really
you know built for bass it's more for
the mids and the treble so that's where
you're going to hear those highs and
mids on this so if you're looking for
that boom boom sound you're not going to
get that hook up some speakers you're
good to go but if you're looking just
for good Clarity audio all that kind of
stuff these speakers are absolutely
awesome for that I was surprised that
they're able to pump this kind of sound
out of a device this thin this is very
very amazing on this and we got speakers
here on the top and on the side here so
you really getting these sort of
surround audio coming from this device
now we're going to do we're going to
show you a little bit more of the
display we're going to do it by our
special video test that we find on
YouTube to show you the rich blacks and
by the way I can still type on this
right here if I want to the keyboard
pops up we're good to go so I can bring
this down like there and this is perfect
think about this
as an artist as a creative
that I could actually have this as my
workstation
I mean if I'm drawing using procreate or
something like that I got a stylus or if
I'm doing some little bit of Photoshop
or Lightroom this is beautiful for that
[Music]
wow
awesome
honey has never looked so good
oh I'm hungry now
look at the details on this seriously
look at the details this 2.5 k o LED
display from Boe partnered with Asus on
this is amazing
absolutely spellbounder I just can't get
over this think about this for a second
you know just a few years ago we were
seeing foldable phones coming into the
play right and we had to Baby them you
couldn't you know people were destroying
the screens on accident there was dust
getting into the hinges there was a lot
of issues it was growing pains in the
industry
coming into 2022
we now have a 17 inch
foldable device full to 12.5 inch can
stand like this you can have a Bluetooth
keyboard attached to this
is like a three in one device
that's going to change how we use
tablets PCS laptops going forward now
again this is going to be a one of those
devices that may not fit everybody's
needs fair enough
it's not meant to it's meant to push the
industry forward
and that's what this thing is doing
right here I can't believe honestly I
wasn't expecting it to be like this I
thought okay foldable 17 inch display we
got to baby it is it gonna work really
well but it does so much they've thought
of so many things in this device
to make it so usable and user friendly
I'm impressed Jackie what do you think
yo I think it's gonna be the next
productivity and portability device out
there man wow that's deep yeah Xeno what
do you think
it's beautiful
solzino ever says it's beautiful Jill
come over here come over here come over
a second Gerald is wearing a nice shirt
for this event today what do you think
of the display well it's very nice cool
right
we always use this YouTube video for
OLED tests this is impressive it is
right those are our thoughts here on the
Zenbook 17 fold OLED from Asus big
thanks once again Ace of Singapore for
allowing us to test drive this briefly
hopefully we'll get the production unit
in here sometime soon and we can do a
full review on it with that guys if you
like this video please like And
subscribe to the channel helps us out a
lot take care stay safe and we'll chat
to you soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]